[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir ça va je trouve vous avez changé
un truc j'ai changer de parfum
ah c'est ça ouais c'est vrai que sachiez
pas c'est le muscle chez pas ses traits
fins petit lauriers après on va partir
en pause à vous reviendra très bien
j'aime laisser pousser la barbe un petit
peu j'ai pas trouvé d'accord je suis
très émue sorte c'est ma 22ème chronique
avec vous non ça veut dire que je suis
tout proche de la fin que du début
alors c'est le taux final je plaisante
bien des crocs aux murs et que débattez
avec le mois alors ce soir dans mes
lauriers le résumé d'un venue de booba
dans touche pas à mon poste
kelly d'ovalie mathématicienne et qui ne
restent ceux qui ne respectent plus
l'animal atteint j'aime pas du tout le
bilan de doc gynéco depuis qu il est
chroniqueur est un nouvel épisode du
tarbes a bien sûr alors hier soir
c'était l'événement recevait celui que
l'on surnomme le duc de boulogne
b2o ou encore hassan hauts-de-seine que
j'aime beaucoup plus connu sous le nom
de booba c'était marrant parce que
j'avais jamais vu les chroniqueurs
tremblay autant posant des questions à
l'invité il transpirait on était super
content d'avoir mais on va dire que
booba c'est pas l'inviter qui va faire
des monologues quand vous le posez une
question est et s'il bat n'a pas envie
n'a pas envie je remets donc à booba le
laurier de l'invité qui n'est pas venu
là pour jouer à tu l'as vu mon cul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre l amérique n est tout de suite
vous avez annoncé la couleur façon à
proposer plein de choses il a dit non à
rien c'est bizarre parce qu'on patois
booba dit non à tout gilles verdez aubin
est ce que vous regrettez la bagarre ni
non je regarde la télé crochet tout ça
ce vol c'est tout pas du tout vous
voulez peut-être que tu sois dans le
jury de the voice site ont ils sont même
pas vous approcher tu l'aurais pas fait
non tu avais pas de démission comme ça
non problème de nouvelles histoires de
meuf entre vous deux non tu vas voir le
match non j'aurais pu être le gilet
jaune doit non non ok rien puisqu'il
leur a appris qu'il était le fils
spirituel d'une star internationale
d'art 4 francky vincent épique et tu es
comme sortie en championne qui s'appelle
points qui valent cent parce qu'à mes
débuts quand j'ai décidé ce qu'il fait
avec booba c'est qui les cachent
charisme à dire oui mais pourquoi tu ne
fait pas en tunisie où tu vas dire
pourrais tu le fais pas en suisse n'a
jamais tunisie n'a aucun sens et aux
réponses et à la tunisie
ah ben c'est que c'est mon pays on s'en
fout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça vous n'avez pas poser une question
vos goûts bellaïd pascal mais c'est tout
les autres aussi bombe à tous en fête
est ce que voulait revoir le même on
enchaîne d'azur aux chaînes on
enchaînera tout à l'heure alors qu'elle
lui devait lui est arrivé sur la pointe
des pieds dans touche pas à mon poste
alors certains été scandalisé parce
qu'au début et nous a fait croire
qu'elle était djette mais moi ça n'a
jamais choqué parce que ça fait neuf ans
que les chroniqueurs font croire qu'ils
sont spécialistes médias pearson or
depuis quelques temps kelly je trouve
qu'elle se comporte très mal rêve ou
cyril elle ne vous respecte plus elle
prend ses aises
je remets qualité dvd le laurier de la
rebelle et vous aviez vu en boîte
ouais exactement c'est ouf je sais
chanter my way a rien d'autre à dire et
tu étais déjà djette à nong et toujours
pas assez la chape aujourd'hui
joe rester là dedans tu peux aller 10
minutes un petit peu aux dix minutes
comme elle c'est que vraiment couché sa
mère il fait chaud vous direz c'est ses
béquilles que nous envoyer ça si vous
voulez c'est quoi tout permis l artois
qui se passe là je co anime c'est parce
qu'on avait dit je vais lui parler elle
excusez moi allez voir si je suis pas
dehors cet oratoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est même toi je te sens choqué non a
du répondant c'est bien matin et alors
alors d'accord on comprend pas toujours
ce qu'ils racontent il a parfois des
absents aux absences pendant l'émission
il est devenu indispensable
et je vais vous montrer pourquoi donc je
vous remets le laurier de la meilleure
recrue de touche pas à mon poste de ces
trente dernières années
c'est mon frère je laime vraiment
d'amour doc gynéco
au début vous êtes hyper contents
d'accueillir doc gynéco série sauf que
une heure après vous êtes déjà obligé de
le recadrer
ici il ya des gens qui nous regardent
j'ai des chiffres qui tombent tous les
quarts d'heure à un cours de ce document
les quartiers pas pu résister on dit que
doc gynéco et mou mais dès qu'il s'agit
de meuf
il est vice président jean michel merde
[Musique]
on va vous faire
véronic dicaire ne veut plus revenir en
france depuis sa rencontre avec doc je
peux me déplacer les vols ça monsieur
qu'il fasse et donc gynéco est le seul
chroniqueurs qui croient que c'est le
début de l'émission
alors qu'il est 21h12 c'est con à
l'antenne bonsoir à tous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bravo avec nous magnifique aime bien
matt maths mais pas reconnu ouest et qui
si on s'est vus normes je n'ai pas fait
attention tu m'as pris au dépourvu c'est
mon éducation hypra sérieux mais entre m
a vu son entrée en tant que danseur il a
vu l'entrée des frères on arrivé là la
poche
merci docteur finir à pour finir chaque
semaine tous les mouvements cyril pour
finir je met en exergue tous les moments
vous moquer de tous les chroniqueurs
honteusement alors si je devais tout
diffuser ma chronique forêt 2h30 c'est
un peu le cas de ce soir d'ailleurs sa
famille de venir jouer avec vous mais
vous dites souvent que je suis un tabac
mais vous vous conservez encore cette
semaine le laurier du plus gros tard
baba ministère de l'intérieur pour
traquer jusque là là là là là là là elle
devient chiant merci mon canard mon
lapin ou encore ma biche se retrouvent
tout en bas du classement
comment vous appelez les rosiers mon
vieux et les us et qualité et lui nous
avez vu c'est la personnalité préférée
des 15 34 ans jacky c'est faut arrêter
le calme toi
à maxime brel c'est vrai mais vous savez
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]